yeah welcome to this video yeah this
video actually hinders have little
content in itself it only serves to link
to another video and this is what you
see on the screen here um I've done an
interview here with Brian Castro on the
chest and do the a stone from the USO
started um a website competitor
straining calm it's a brand new site
form of a block mostly about chess
improvement and learning chess and TM
asked me to do an interview with him
which I did and this interviewing now
has put on youtube so this video here is
mostly to to link you and point you to
this video you'll learn if you
interested something about my beginning
ingest some training ideas some some
some tips some news about the channel
maybe so it's worth watching if you are
regular visitor of my channel so make
sure to watch the video and go to a
brine site it's just in development so
you'd have some articles there already
but it keep will keep on growing yeah
thanks for watching and we'll make sure
to check out the video on the side I'm